For our final unit, we're going to start by exploring Inverse Functions.
Inverse functions are a way that we can undo what we do to an input. For
example, if we doubled a number the inverse of that would be dividing it by 2.
Before we get into the fancy notation, let's just look at a mapping between two
sets. Here are three ordered pairs. The first set is a, b and c. And the second
set is 2, 3, and 1. A maps to 2, b maps to 3, and c maps to 1. We could also
show this using a mapping diagram. Here's the first set, containing a, b and c.
And here's the second set, containing the numbers 1, 2 and 3. We said a maps to
2, b maps to 3, and c maps to 1. Now, this would be considered a function,
since every input has 1 distinct and unique output. In other words, every
single output has one unique input that creates it. Now, let's consider a
different function. This time this function will have the ordered pairs 2a, 3b
and 1c. This function is the inverse function of this one. And we could express
it with this mapping. Notice that here we had the inputs of 1, 2 and 3 here,
here and here. Now these input correspond to different outputs. 1 corresponds
to c, 2 corresponds to a, and 3 corresponds to b. Look carefully at these two
functions and their mappings to figure out their relationship. What do you
think is the relationship between a function and its inverse? Once you've taken
some time to think about this, I want you to try and answer this next question.